o
peço desculpas se levantarem por favor
está quase na hora do almoço e vou cris
para desafiar os no futuro então optou
espera obter em palmas
vamos lá 1 2 3
cheguei lá peguei paulo
o dono boca roxa
basta mandou a mulher gasta aqui na sala
vai e pronto
eu vou te contar então uma história e
convidar é viajar muniz buscar que é a
metamorfose do telex o ano 2016 a
desafiar o futuro através de uma
história uma história que o parque tem
um ponto de partida
no âmbito morfose tem sido um mmo foz
nos últimos meses ainda não computou um
ano esta metamorfose ainda está em
processo de vir mas é uma grande o termo
fosse que já está em um ouvido
é muita gente já está envolvido também
muitas empresas em falar está aqui hoje
no tse para poder partilhar com vocês
esta história chamas também um desafio
ao futuro que é o que tem feito dislikes
ele sair da zona de conforto e criar
essa própria estamos faz primeiro no meu
corpo e depois na minha vida e
consequentemente na vida das pessoas
então era um aviso não é burro manga
goiaba manga roth com quem estava numa
indústria eo liberou os gases gols não é
porque as indústrias são sempre moldadas
e são comunicadas para imagens de
mulheres bonitas de imagens bonitas é
tudo que é comunicado
nunca vi uma mulher gorda não é verdade
da mentira já virou uma gordurinha
comunicar um sul
sabe uma gordinha comunicar um
supermercado
não pois não sabia logo vem a comunicar
qualquer outro produto não então essa
mulher gorda tem uma já agora já estou
assim mais uma num mercado onde só
imperam as gajas boas visão ela quando
propôs um programa de televisão ela não
foi nenhum kasting ela não não concorreu
há nenhum para nenhum em um cassino foi
bater em uma porta não foi nenhum
concurso ela se reunia viver um basta à
sua habilidade e por acaso ela tem
jornalista e em referiu escrever o seu
próprio programa de televisão portava
cansada
a energia de na onda e não consegui
movimentar até duas das articulações e
de uma data domingo vivido coisas que já
não faziam parte da sua vida e de seus
40 anos que ela iria fazer e sabem por
que sabem quem sabe ela preferiu sair de
sua zona de conforto ea zona de conforto
dela era essa laranja não era uma zona e
nada confortável era uma zona que não
lhe permitia fazer quase nada
ela já nós conseguimos china já não têm
energia para trabalhar então era uma
zona de conforto muito muito muito
instável
através dessa história ela conseguiu
criar o seu próprio programa de
televisão e um projeto que chama o meu
peso prefeito foi nada mais nada menos
do que o reality show inspiracional onde
esta senhora que saiu de sua zona de
conforto que era laranja chegou é uma
empresa que era um canal de televisão e
diz que a emagrecido posso imaginar uma
pessoa obesa em cima com mais 90 quilos
chegar a uma empresa em um mercado em
crise não é porque nós estamos a falar
de crise estamos a fabricar morfose
estamos a falar do dinheiro não é
ninguém dá dinheiro a ninguém sem ter
nada em troca
principalmente no reality show antes
messi com um batom clarinho acima do
normal do que um programa normal de
quatro semanas vamos pagar um pouquinho
é o que vamos ficar ali vai mudar ali na
um reality show envolve uma equipa
tentar 24 horas conosco tentar
acompanhar envolve um volume muito alto
ela chegou essa empresa e eles olhem eu
tenho que este projecto é o reality show
eu sou autora a jornalista e produtora
executiva e compromisso emagrecer
a primeira resposta foi amarga que seria
gasto pago não acreditam que outra vez a
porta já disse que angola e em
moçambique nunca falou de obesidade
nunca soube da novidade como um problema
temos que olhar pra esse problema com um
problema sério uma vez que existem
números muito altos de obesidade
vamos tratar isso com um conteúdo por
visível opa traçar outro projeto e 82
voltei para trás back my passados seis
meses a porta teve já vi que eu de
estruturar isso eu tenho uma clínica
time misto e químico outro e o canal
televisão já ficou a 58 não querem mais
viver e realmente olhou cair
nós temos sempre descobrir talentos
musicais e rodar nós não temos tantos
talentos musicais
temos anotemos pronto o que o governo
fez comigo diz também que os animais ser
ok então lá foi é seguro e estava sem
perceber na um cheiro da fil muitos
muitos muitos laos tentar novamente
vender o seu projecto mas não emagrecia
explodir aqui ouviu essa minha gorda uma
empresa e uma cultura um canal de
televisão
várias empresas várias marcas e várias
pessoas e com muita perseverança elas
envolverão as todas neste projeto lua
país que em angola onde estamos todos
nós eo limite é o céu
nós temos todos agora que se conseguiu
pela primeira vez realizar um projeto
vivo que o 'reality show' inspiracional
não não é que o soluço dizem as lágrimas
a toda hora não é infelizmente onde se
anda a batata também não é não é o
reality show o espírito final quando
alguém deu a cara pelo virado não
daquela forma trágica estamos todos
habituados noé e gorda e pois aqui seis
meses volta 13 por de pinhas não foi
dessa forma que essa minha rua e viu o
cara ela realmente estilo problema da
obesidade ao nosso e vai escalar o mundo
não é problema também está no youtube e
decidiu dar a cara e criar e diz uma
empresa que agora existe essa história
que tenho aqui para vos contar através
de um projeto pessoal e de uma história
pessoal
se cria um projetos profissionais e que
nós conquistamos é pensar em criar um
projeto e oferecer esse projeto
o nosso cliente que primeiramente será
isso canal de televisão que nós queremos
veicular ou essa revista que nós
queremos vender a história eu falo como
jornalista também e produtora de
conteúdo
nós temos que saber por que estamos a
fazer não só por termos uma cara bonita
neste caso uma barriga grande não é a
favor
nós temos que saber por que estamos a
fazer e temos que saber como é que vamos
reduzir essa pessoa como é que vamos
seduzir
olha eu já não se consegue subir porque
eu queria usar notas de ninguém mas como
é que vamos reduzir essa empresa e como
é que nós vamos criar conteúdo à volta
do problema é tão grande que é observava
tem 40 anos
o metrô e 53 92 quilos e meio já tentou
todas as dietas nunca perdeu peso
hoje começa aqui o maior desafio da sua
vida
alcançar o ps prefeito esse grande
desafio da minha vida continua a ser o
maior desafio da minha vida e é um
grande desafio estar a falar com vocês
etapa que foi lá tão rápido é porque eu
tenho aqui umas duas horas é falar com
vocês e a contar esta história que teve
muito x muitos nãos e ainda tem um
caminho enorme pela frente ainda tem
muitas reuniões também pela frente
porque continua não é só um projeto por
visível
teve muita gente envolvida mil
tenho muita muita alegria também tem
muita tristeza não é fácil mudar de
comportamento não é fácil assumir esse
comportamento como uma como uma forma de
vida não é para para como uma caminhada
não é e não é fácil
agora quando eu sei um pouco e quando
cheguei fui sá fizera que os quitutes
você está entrando lá pra mim pipa mas
ela não não eu penso que o pai pois ela
não time que assim não porque se você
também tem que ter foco delas
devem saber o que estou a fazer uma das
coisas que acontecem muito jenny e eu
vou comprar os lados
no outro dia estava lindo bairro labeouf
dos lados ae - a senhora como isolado e
assim o acumulado mas você fez aqui o
programa de maxímino claro mostra
ficamos sempre o outro lado das coisas
que fazemos mas a vida continua eo que
nós continue que nós fazemos é o nosso
trabalho também está e que acaba por ser
um trabalho mas também é vida inspira
outras pessoas e é um projeto que eu
gostaria realmente em angola a sua
inovação ea série e 89 tem imensa sorte
das 20 empresas que com quem eu
trabalhei no meu penso que faço e posso
dizer cuidar delas continuam ligadas ao
meu peso prefeito em tabelas querem
continuar a trabalhar como eu penso que
foi porque finalmente perceberam qual é
que é o problema da obesidade
a virada é um problema muito muito muito
grande
e melhor ainda quando nos tornamos isso
um conteúdo por vivo
melhor ainda com nós atribuímos o
patrocinador é e ao parceiro a
possibilidade de eu sentir tua mãe quase
um sina de ter uma responsabilidade
social não só e eu vou te ensinar esse
programa eu vou patrocinar esse projeto
mas eu nem vou ver se nos conteúdos nós
podemos conseguir criar conteúdos para
diz sobre saúde sobre real que o style e
notaram sim pra apostar nas graças
nós temos num país em crise é rodado
nós temos habituados a ouvir mãos e
rodado mas nós temos que ter esperança e
desafiar esse futuro nós vamos começar a
desafiá lo olhando para nós e para os
nossos problemas não só porque temos uma
cara bonita só porque já fizemos muitas
coisas lá atrás mas sim poder por um
presente que estamos agora eu por
exemplo nós temos agora e este é um
projecto de metamorfose é um presente de
desafio e é um presente muito feliz e eu
estou muito feliz por estar aqui com
vocês hoje
e mais feliz ainda por apesar de estas
vicissitudes histórias não ter vergonha
nenhuma por não ter vergonha é roubar e
não fica claro é um clássico mas também
não teve conhecimento de nós
caímos no chão e podemos olhar para as
suas assim de frente e assim que olha o
meu futuro é assim que eu olho para o
futuro de angola e assim que olha eu
penso que foi como metamorfose e assim
que olha para você explica que as que o
terek holanda deve continuar e o limite
é o céu e é por isso que hoje não têm
teto porque o limite é o céu
um bem haja para você hoje sou muito
repor faz bem obrigada